as some of you may have seen on my
Twitter I did a collaboration with Cinna
fix and the guys from homemade movies
needless to say put me in a very matrix'
mood so I was like let's just review the
matrix let's do that right now
seems the thing to do yes
the matrix so the matrix came out in
1999 it was a sci-fi the likes of which
myself and many other people had never
seen ever before this thing blew
people's minds man it came out the same
years the Phantom Menace so there was
one revolutionary sci fi that came out
that year and not only does it have cool
special effects and the nostalgia going
for it but the matrix is actually still
a cool movie the matrix stars Keanu
Reeves he's his computer hacker type guy
he's not really fulfilled in his life
classic protagonist story right there
but then Laurence Fishburne finds him
and he's like I give you a choice neo
blue pill or red pill he takes the red
pill then he learns the truth a truth
which is actually itching at your mind
too because you know something in this
world is not right like the first big
special effect you see in this movie is
Trinity does that Karate Kid crank kick
and she suspends in midair and the
camera turns around she kicks a guy and
you're like what was that because you
hadn't seen that before in your life but
even for the universe in this movie it
lets you know something is not right in
this world spoiler alert for people who
haven't watched The Matrix the world is
a lie it is not the year 1999 is closer
to 2199 humanity in its entirety is
plugged in their brains are plugged into
a computer and they think they're living
their lives it's pretty much the most
realistic MMO ever yet the world around
you
it's an MMO or or lies it's how I can
describe it yeah machines have enslaved
mankind but they did it in a way that
terminators didn't really think of these
machines were like well if we plug
everyone in and unleash them for their
energy we have an unlimited power supply
called human bodies and we'll give them
the matrix so they can still I don't
know think they're having sex
I guess it's why they did it they did it
cuz they're nice but the world is
decimated people are living on ships the
only means they have to fight machines
they have an EMP Pole so they can shoot
out when the Sentinels are coming after
him Trinity said in this movie that is
the only weapon they have against the
machine the only one they do not have
mechs with automatic weapons apparently
they don't the first movie told us that
and Laurence Fishburne firmly believes
that neo Keanu Reeves is the one who's
going to save humanity and liberate
everyone from this this movie put Keanu
Reeves on the map before this he was Ted
Theodore Logan in which he was all like
whoa but in the matrix he's a like whoa
and that my friends is range and yeah
I'll give him speed but let's be honest
the matrix was his big movie what I love
about the matrix is it gives us
superheroes essentially Whitney
no Trinity Morpheus all that crew when
they hack into the matrix they're able
to bend the rules of the matrix like any
other computer program which means they
can move faster jump higher run up walls
it gives us some of the coolest action
scenes you can think of these action
scenes today still are badass and what I
love is the matrix is so full of special
effects but they are a means to tell the
story still some of it can be seen as a
little indulgent but you let it slide
because it's done so well about style
and execution man really seriously that
one scene where Neos dodging bullets and
the bullets are going by him the cameras
spinning around him he's all badass and
bending backward no human being on the
face of the planet seeing that for the
first time had the reaction good nobody
nobody not one we were all like oh this
was mind-blowing [ __ ] right here and
this movie has a great villain there are
agents in the matrix these agents are
put there to hunt down the resistance
they can bend the rules just like the
hackers can the main one is agent Smith
this put Hugo Weaving on the map yeah
without the matrix you wouldn't know
Hugo Weaving and that would be a sad day
for Humanity agent Smith is so badass
he's all like mr. Anderson it appears
you're living two lives he talks in a
way where if you talk to this guy you'd
be like I don't think you're human I've
talked with people who talk like that
and I still do not think they are human
agent Smith is menacing he's got to be
one of the most iconic villains and
movies ever cool special effects cool
premise post-apocalyptic world don't in
a way in which you can still see the old
world but it's all [ __ ] it's not
real or is it [ __ ] because in the
movie would be like what is real how do
you define real which feeds into another
point that the matrix has a lot of
philosophical themes to it which isn't
unheard of in a sci-fi it's really cool
to see in a movie like this he'd be just
as easy for the movie to be like oh cool
slow-mo and that's all awesome is a
revolutionary special-effects and that's
enough to carry the movie but it wasn't
it has more guts to it I like seeing
that it was a clashing of genres the
likes of which you hadn't really seen
yet it's a crock pot it's a melting pot
of Awesome from the get-go the matrix
made its mark on people and cinema
movies were spoofing the matrix within
the first year of its release people
were talking about it within the first
week and they haven't stopped talking
about it since it's always scary
watching a nostalgic movie that you
thought was awesome years ago and you
haven't seen in a while you sit
watch it you're like okay this might
suck now don't want it to but it's a
reality of the situation
luckily the matrix still awesome in fact
the matrix is awesome tacular
and yes if you want to see my
collaboration I did with Cinna fix and
the guys from homemade movies if you
don't know what they do they ultimately
take scenes from movies and/or trailers
and they recreate them shot-for-shot
with absolutely no budget whatsoever so
all the props are really simple props
it's like the movie be kind rewind if
they were accurate with the camera
placement in their shots it takes
creativity to do something like this and
I love seeing that kind of creativity
it's funny as hell and it's entertaining
and they wanted to do the rooftop scene
in the matrix you know the scene where
neo dodges the bullets and they were
like um do you want to be our Neil I was
like sure so you can click on that if
you have your annotations on if you
don't don't worry I put a link below
because I'm here for you always got a
plan B for you check it out it was fun
as hell to do I like that kind of
creativity on YouTube so the matrix did
you see it when it came out did you see
it later what do you think about it does
it still hold up today whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more cuz I know come fear
you